翻訳: Kiyokazu Konishi
校正: Hiroko Kawano
こちら みなさん ご存知ですね
ランドセルです
日本人には 非常に なじみが深いものですが
このランドセルにはですね
たいてい 学校から配られたプリントが
こんな風に 入っているものですよね
（笑）
こんな風にですね
おかしいですね
今日は TEDxAnjoに出られて良かったです
（笑）
あっ ありました これですね
ちょっと しわくちゃなんですけれども
このプリント この１枚のプリントが
子どもたちの 睡眠不足を解消して
朝の遅刻を減らした
きっかけとなった と聞かれたら
みなさんは どう思われますでしょうか
このプリント 実は僕が作って
学校で配って頂いたものなんですが
このプリントのタイトルには
夜９時以降の スマホ SNSの使用を
禁止します と書いてあります
今日は これ 子どもたちの
夜９時以降 スマホ SNSの使用禁止
ということをテーマに お話をしたいと思います
しかし これだけはみなさんにひとつだけ
あらかじめ知っておいて頂きたい
ということがあります
それは このお話は
子どもたちのスマホ SNSの使用を
制限する話 ではない ということなんです
そのことだけ みなさんの頭の隅っこに
置いといて頂いて
このお話 お聞き頂ければなと 思います
僕は ２年前になりますが
平成25年度に
この安城市内にある中学校で
PTAの会長を務めさせて頂いておりました
当然 中学校のPTAですので
その当時は 中学生の子どもがおりました
今はもう高校生になっちゃいましたが
この子は 中学生時代は 自分は
スマホは必要ないと 言っていたので
うちではその子に スマホ 携帯電話を
持たせてはいませんでした
ですので 僕自身が 子どもたち―
とりわけ中学生の子どもたちが
どのようにスマホ SNSを使っているのかと
いうことをあまり良く知りませんでした
そんなある日 うちの中学では
ふれあい会議というものが 開かれました
このふれあい会議 というのは
いじめをなくそう ということを目的に
年に数回 生徒会が主催をして開く会議です
そこに 僕たちPTAの役員とか
町内会の役員といった地域の大人が
アドバイザーとして参加をする
という形で開かれる会議です
そのふれあい会議で一度
スマホの使い方をみんなで考えよう
というテーマで
開かれた会がありました
そこに出席をして 初めて
子どもたちのスマホ SNSの使い方が
危機的状況にある
ということを知ったのです
それは例えば お風呂に入って出てくると
もう未読のメッセージが
200件も300件も来ている とか
宿題やテスト勉強をしたくても
机の横でスマホが
ピロリンピロリンピロリンピロリンと
鳴り続けて集中出来ない といったこと
そして そのスマホを一度見てしまうと
相手には既読のマークが出てしまうので
そのスマホ 一生懸命メッセージを読んで
返事を送らなければいけない
それを怠ってしまうと
明日の友達関係が もう変わってしまう
かも知れない という危機感
これはもう自分たちの力では
制御不能なのだと 言うのです
しかも 例えば うちは 夜９時までだから
という家庭のルールがあったとしても
それをグループのメンバー全員には
なかなか浸透させることが出来ない
といったことも挙げられました
それまで僕は 子どもたちはみな
楽しく使っているのかな
と思っていましたが 案外そうではない
ということを知りました
そして 子どもたち自身の力でも
家庭のルールでも
何ともすることが出来ないのであれば
学校かPTAが 何とかするべきではないか
と考えるようになりました
加えて 決定的な事件が
起きてしまいました
平成25年6月に広島で起きた事件
当時16才の女の子が
殺害されてしまいました
殺害したのも同じ16才の女の子
同級生だったということです
SNSでのやりとりがトラブルになり
集団暴行事件に発展してしまい
７人が逮捕された という事件です
それまでにも 同様の少年事件は
いくつかありましたが
この事件は ただのトラブルが
SNSによって 事件に発展しやすい
また その事件が SNSによって
より大きくなってしまう
という傾向にあると感じました
非常に衝撃的な事件でした
何が衝撃的かというと
極々当たり前に どこにでも
起こりうる事件だということなんです
もしかしたらウチの中学の生徒が
被害に遭っていたかも知れない
加害者になっていたかも知れない
僕たちの子どもたちが
みなさんのお子さんが
被害者にも加害者にも
なり得る事件だということなんです
これは何としても 食い止めなければいけない
しかし 警察は 事件が起きてからでなければ
動いてはくれません
こうした事件から子どもたちを守るには
親が何とかするしかない
そう 確信した事件でした
しかし実際には どうすれば
子どもたちを守ることが出来るのか
ということが何も分かりませんでした
それがまた 衝撃的でした
それでも何とかしなければ
ウチの中学の生徒も
被害にあってしまうかも知れない
非常に大きな危機感でした
そこで 学校の先生とも連携し
一緒に考え作ったのが このプリントです
冒頭でお話ししました通り このプリント―
夜９時以降の
スマホ SNSの使用を禁止します
と 書いてあります
では 夜９時に使うのを止めれば
子どもたちを守ることが出来るのか と言えば
それは違います
これだけで子どもたちを守れません
ではなぜ 夜９時―
なぜ使用禁止なのか
僕たちPTAは 子どもたちを守りたい
という一心で活動しています
子どもたちを守りたいと
考えて考えて考え抜いて
出来ることがこのプリント１枚
出すだけなんです
ならばこの１枚のプリントに
最大限の力を込めて子どもたちに配りたい
そのために使った言葉が
夜９時 使用禁止 という言葉なのです
このプリントを読んで
なぜ９時なんだ なぜ使用禁止なんだ―
ということをきっかけにして スマホの使い方を
みなさんに考えて頂きたい
スマホ 便利です SNSはとても楽しい
しかし その裏側で 毎日のように
様々な事件や事故が起きている
どんな事件や事故が起きているのか
なぜ起きてしまうのか
どうしたら防ぐことができるのか
ということを
保護者のみなさん一人一人に考えてもらいたい
子どもたちにも 一人一人に考えてもらいたい
そして 親子で話し合って頂きたい
もし みなさんに 親子で話し合って
頂くことが出来たのなら
夜９時とか 10時なんて
どうでもいいんですよ
使用禁止なんてしなくてもいいんです
それだけ 親子で話し合う ということに
大きな力があるのです
夜９時以降使用禁止 ということは
最終的な措置ではなく
ただの 考えるきっかけ
親子で話し合うきっかけなんです
これが この取り組みの一番大切な中身の部分
この取り組みの真意なのです
しかし このプリント１枚配っただけでは
その真意までは
なかなかみなさんに
理解して頂くことは出来ません
このプリント読んで なんだこんなもの
と言って クシャクシャとして
カバンに突っ込まれて 底のほうで潰れている
簡単に想像してしまいます
先ほどのランドセルみたいに
そこで このプリントには
もう一つ 仕掛けを作りました
それがこの プリントの一番下の部分―
本来ならば
学校の電話番号と 教頭先生の名前が
書いてあるべきところに
僕の名前と 僕の個人のメールアドレスを
載せました
これが 僕の覚悟の表れ
どんな意見でも受けますよ
議論上等 かかってこいや という気持ちです
案の定 このプリントが配られたその日から
とてもたくさんのメールが来ました
その全てが 批判 苦情のメールです
それは 例えば
「それって家庭の問題でしょ」
「子どもにスマホを持たせる親の責任でしょ」
「夜９時になって 子どもたちが ピタッと
止めるなんて 考えられないけどね」
そして 「PTAにそんな権限あるの」
というもの
PTAにそんな権限無いんです
無いけど PTAが 親が 動かなければ
子どもたちを守ることができない
だからやるんです
ということと 先ほどの真意の部分—
夜９時以降使用禁止は 最終的な措置ではなく
親子で話し合うきっかけなんだよ ということを
全てのメールに書いて返信しました
すると ほとんどのメールから
また返事がもらえたんですね
「すみませんでした」 「理解をしました」
「協力させて頂きます」
分かってもらえたんだな って 思いました
もちろんこのメールだけでは足りませんので
PTA総会とか 子どもたちの集まる集会
人の集まるところ 様々なところで
このお話をさせて頂きました
これがもう一つ大切なこと
夜９時以降使用禁止は 最終的な措置ではなく
親子で話し合うきっかけなんだよ ということを
みなさんに理解をして頂く ということ
そのために 言って言って言いまくる
ということが大切だと思います
そして最後に もう一つ大切なことがあります
それが 保護者向けの スマホ教室
保護者が 情報が少な過ぎ
知らな過ぎなんです
それでは 親子で話し合う
なんてことは到底出来ません
保護者が 子ども以上に
正しい知識をきっちりと身につけて
初めて 親子で対等に話し合うことが出来る
親子で話し合って初めて
子どもを守る力を得ることが出来るのです
そのために 保護者向けのスマホ教室を
学校などで開いて頂いて
保護者のみなさんにきっちりと
正しい知識を身につけて頂く ということ
必ず必要と考えています
この３つ
夜９時以降使用禁止は 最終的な措置ではなく
親子で話し合うきっかけなんだよ ということ
それをみなさんに理解して頂く ということ
そして 保護者のみなさんに
正しい知識を身に付けて頂くこと
この３つがあって
初めてこの取り組みはうまく行く
そう考えてウチの中学では
活動を続けて来ました
それでも 直ぐには結果は出ないだろうな
と思っていました
２年 ３年かけて少しずつ広げて行かなければ
いけないなと そう感じていました
しかし うちの中学では
この取り組みを始めて 約３ヶ月たったところで
アンケートを取ってくださいました
この取り組みが始まってどうだったか
という内容
とてもたくさんの生徒が
「助かった」 と答えたそうです
「良かった」 ではなく
「助かった」 と答えたところに
この問題の深さが見えるような
気がしませんか？
実際には 目に見える効果として
子どもたちの夜の時間が
SNSから解放されて
睡眠時間 勉強時間が
確保出来るようになりました
そして 朝の遅刻が今はほとんどありません
この朝の遅刻に関しては
先生方もすごく頑張ってくださっていますので
こればっかりが要因とは
考えらないんですけれども
それでも 夜の睡眠時間が
確保出来ている ということは
ひとつの大きな要因だと考えられます
また 実際に親子で話し合ったという
ご家庭にもお話をうかがいますと
ただ禁止 と言うだけでは
子どもたちもなかなか
受け入れてはくれませんが
どんな行動が
どんな危険につながっているのか
ということをきっちりと話し合えば
「あっ これは自分のためなんだな」
と理解してくれて
親の話も聞き入れやすい
というお話が ありました
また 「その後は 問題も無く使えている」
とか
「使い方が目に余る場合も
保護者の少しの注意で
自分で使い方を改められるようになった」
また 「保護者が特に何も言わなくても
最近使い過ぎかな と―
使い方を自分で改められるようになった」
など 保護者の目に見える効果も
現れて来ているようです
この取り組み 夜９時以降使用禁止は―
夜９時以降使用禁止 という
この取り組みは
いま 全国的に少しずつ 広がりつつあります
しかし その取り組みが
もし このプリント１枚出すだけであったなら
先ほど僕がもらったような批判 苦情が
たくさん来て
いつの間にか この取り組み自体が
無くなってしまうんではないか
と危惧してしまいます
それでは 子どもたちを守ることが出来ない
だからこそ 今日のお話
ぜひ 参考にして頂ければなと 思います
全ては 子どもたちのために
ありがとうございました
（拍手）